Jamie wheel hey man welcome to flow
sessions it's detective en that's what
we've called it in honor of course of
not just you know the state of flow but
our sponsor flow kana but um you know
we're all we're all aching for more flow
in our lives so I thought it'd be a an
appropriate title for these
conversations it's great to have you
here man yeah how are you great amazing
well to start things off you know I
first came across your work a number of
years ago and was instantly infatuated
with many of your ideas I remember it
was a talk a TEDx talk from Black Rock
City in Burning Man
and I was immediately hooked by the
title was called from altered states to
altered traits hacking the flow state
and without even watching it I just kind
of felt like the title was it just spoke
to me immediately because so much of so
many of the moments that have defined my
life the moments that take my breath
away the moments I remember with
fondness have been moments that occur in
altered states of consciousness
mythopoetic States states of Rhapsody
and reverie and you know before I
learned about flow and about you we
tended to think of these states as half
hazard they show up when they show up
and we have no say over staging their
preconditions and yet with your TEDx
talk even with the title the whole idea
that we could go from altered states to
altered traits told me that maybe
there's something to be learned about
like changing parts of ourselves to more
readily access these sacred states that
spoke to me so for those listening you
know
would you mind kind of going into the
basic thesis
and behind that wonderful treatise from
altered states to altered traits the
show great and also full hat tip to
Houston Smith who was a famed scholar of
religion he was part of Good Friday
experiments and then all those who
finished his career you know he was at
MIT and was in that world made his way
to Berkeley wrote the book of world
religions was one of the more famous
kind of coffee coffee table books of
just high-level but also kind of from an
initiate spointer222 malted states to
altered traits which is one of his and
in fellow one of the maybe maybe lately
yeah there's there's somebody that's
taken over the lead but for decades the
most cited academic article in
psychedelic literature was his and it
was do drugs have religious import I
didn't know that yeah yeah yeah so just
before we begin full head till of
Houston Smith love it well it's funny
it's funny you mention him because was
he the guy that said you you ended the
talk and before we get into it you ended
the talk with a marvelous quote and I
don't know if it was Houston Smith but I
think it was where you said and this
means essentially the same thing as from
altered states to altered traits you
said how might we turn our passing
illuminations into abiding light yeah is
that him yeah okay so then I get it now
so his whole thing from altered states
to alter traits is summed up in the the
poetry of that quote as well how might
we turn our passing illuminations into a
biting light because there therein lies
my real engagement my interest in so
much of the ideas that that you helped
put into the world is do we have the
creative capacity the agency the the
prowess to turn these passing
illuminations you know these these
moments that make it all worthwhile
but that tend to be few and far between
for most people mmm-hmm into abiding
light I mean what are we talking about
here the hacking of consciousness a kind
of
ecstatic transhumanism yeah so so take
us on this little on this journey of
turning our illuminations into abiding
light how did you kind of fall into this
and what is what is the main argument
there well I mean gosh we can well I'll
come at it from like my own trees just
bumbling efforts sure into the space
because for me it was just survival
skills
it was just what on earth was better
than default normal getting hammered and
driving down the road and playing like
mailbox baseball with an axe because we
couldn't find a baseball bat you know
like like just whatever I just like I
will I will look to break this world
rather than be confined in it oh say
that again cuz that's beautiful I will
look to break this world rather than be
confined in it no I guess I just can't
yeah like oh dude I mean that this is
the warrant wonderful essay called the
death of aw in the age of awesome guy
called Henry wise Maier and he had a
line he said I'm as spirituality Wayne's
experience is the new faith and we are
refugees from the mundane and that
sounds pretty pretty similar to your I
guess sensibilities like looking for
something beyond the default world so to
speak yeah 100% yeah and and for me it
was a very simple kind of triumvirate of
you know music mountains and mushrooms
like marijuana like as a state shifter
sure endocannabinoid system yeah well
being yeah in Hodge pattern recognition
and especially combining them don't do
this at home kids but you know basically
every surfer every skier every snowboard
like we all know the jam mm-hmm shift
state prime yourself and then go surf
gravity in in the natural sublime [ __ ]
works and even better and then on your
off nights you know when the moon is
full and the bands in town like the
community gets together
and throws down two improvisational
ecstatic music rinse wash repeat rinse
wash repeat yeah and so for me that was
like oh this is where meaning seems to
arise at least for me natural sublime
psychedelics with deep companions right
and the music of you know what is
derisive they called jam bands but
starting with the Grateful Dead líneas
that came out of Kesey and the
pranksters right was the original
postmodern ecstatic technology you know
and Joseph Campbell acknowledged because
you guys you know with Bill Moyers he
was like hey you know you guys as a band
or effectively in modern day right of a
Lucis really
Joseph Campbell well had to whoa and if
you think about it you're like okay that
is actually I mean the emerging
gobbledygook of the Grateful Dead they
started out as basically a jug band
slash blues band but they were on
high-dose acid and so was their audience
and and you know Jerry Garcia the
guitarist and it sort of you know
charismatic lead of the band they all
noticed that they were they were
creating something and it was something
beyond the playlist and it was something
beyond the notes and that there was a
feedback loop between a psychedelic Lee
enhanced crowd at the acid tests and the
musicians and the music and they to
their credit didn't try and bottle that
lightning and and no one claimed the
ring right no one no one said I mean he
refused he actually constantly gave it
back he's like I will not steer this
thing and it killed him ultimately like
the burden of that but they figured out
a way to create and a coherent field of
novel emergence that was highly embodied
deeply ecstatic and South if it because
because the the Zen koans and I was just
listening driving here actually cuz I
had no serious radio in the rental car
right I turned on the Grateful Dead and
it was then you know I ain't I ain't
often right but I've never been wrong
seldom turns out the way it does in the
song right and once in a while you can
get shown the light and the strangest of
places if you
could it right and like and their song
cannon is littered with with phrases
like that and you could see them showing
up as psychedelic Cohen says living
scripture there show up on t-shirts
there be Calvin and Hobbes there would
be you know like the dancing guys they
would be varying mash up iconography
with these living scriptural lines that
you knew because you'd experienced it
yourself as had tens of thousands of
others that in that moment
in the second set where this you know
where the moon was rising and that song
dropped and it went all the way down
into people's living systems that was
what Joe Campbell was talking about when
he was talking about a right of a lusus
and the idea that not only was it a
[ __ ] good time like I mean if you
think about like rave culture it's just
food foods I was on I was juice to the
gills rolling my face off and I felt
great I loved everybody but there was no
wisdom imparted there's very rarely
lyrics and if they were they were
somewhat Pat right but but Robert hunter
who was the lyricist for the dead it was
a you know scion of a San Francisco you
know literary family deeply steeped in
culture deeply steeped in mythology
deeply steeped in Old Testament New
Testament legends or Western mythologies
all of it so that became a carrier Pat
basically a carrier vessel for a sort of
Western hermetic trickster based
cosmology this is just [ __ ]
fascinating yeah and you convinced it
you know and that big Burning Man which
has done a similar thing in the sense of
sure refusing to name the thing using
the name the thing that allowing a lot
of mass interesting okay so refusing to
name the thing but even though we don't
name the thing we know that there is a
thing and that that thing can heal us of
our fractures and it sounds like you
know you early on found an equation or a
set of triggers guidelines elements that
allow you to pierce through to the
spaces beyond normal or the states north
of happy so if we took if we were to go
back to our initial question of turning
our passing illuminations into abiding
light the question is of course you know
why must we do this why is our default
state to begin with not enough you know
how do you I mean how you know today we
were living in a epidemic of mental
health that's that's going on mental
health crisis I think a United Nations
number I came across said that more
people are committing suicide than are
dying from natural disasters and armed
conflict combined yes so you know for
all of the the fear and the media and
the doom and gloom and the terrorist
attacks and this and that it's really
the the number one danger really is is
your own your own brain your own demons
your own fracturing Xand and what is the
worm at the core of the human condition
to begin with that makes it so that we
have no choice but to find the kid the
keys to the kingdom somehow and turn
these passing illuminations into abiding
light these altered traits in sorry
these altered states in to alter traits
do you think it has to do with you know
the whole Ernest Becker psychoanalytical
take on the human condition that it is
simply our awareness of being mortal
beings that hunts our dreams and makes
it fundamentally intolerable you know
that the only response to the human
condition according to Becker is full
and open psychosis we are naked and
trembling before the Kosmos we you know
Sheldon Sullivan says breathing pieces
of defecating meat destined to die and
ultimately no more significant than a
lizard or a potato so on one literal
grid level right we are these finite
beings that age and die but we are
endowed with imaginations and
cosmologies that allow us to contemplate
infinity and so there the dissonance
between what we can marvel at and what
we can conceive and engender in our
minds with the reality of aging and
death is what makes the fundamental
disquiet of the human condition the worm
at the core so it's like essentially we
either find a goddamn way of turning our
passing illuminations into abiding light
or we [ __ ] kill ourselves
does that does that resonate with you
yeah pretty much like yeah that is 100%
half of the game half of the game you
know and and you know I know you know
this quote as well I think we shared it
before but that music got it I wanna you
know wisdom tells me I'm nothing so
that's the you know decomposing zoo
animal yeah love tells me I'm everything
and between these two banks flows the
river of my life language beautiful I
mean therein lies the problem that's it
it's not even what that little it's not
even what that means cuz of course what
it means is it makes perfect sense right
like wisdom tells me I am nothing love
tells me I am everything and then
between those two banks is my life like
that's true but you know what's also him
beyond measure is is the elegance of
that language the poetry of that phrase
that the fact that we can concoct
something so beautiful to find respite
from our ills you know that we that we
turn to language that we turn to poetry
that we turn to the mythopoetic to find
a relief from this this burden of being
able to ponder the infinite seemingly
capable of anything but to be housed in
you know and Becker's words these heart
pumping breath gasping decaying bodies I
mean yeah it's almost like I mean I
agree I agree with you we got to find
something beyond the normal yeah and and
you seem to have found this equation and
I guess tell us a little bit about the
yeah
the the practical approaches to did you
say music mushrooms and and mountains
and mountains you know what is the the
neurobiology behind why we respond to
these states what is the the science
tell us about our capacities who to pre
construct and to design for these
ecstasy's that take us out of time and
outside of the default setting of
mortality awareness anxiety and the
fibrillating what do you call it the
cul-de-sacs and errormsgs of the nagging
my
let's tell because I think it's
interesting for people to realize that
you know you are aware of the science
and the research and the application and
the reproducibility and the reliability
behind evoking these states
sure what are you calling the trifecta
of ecstasy catharsis and communitas yeah
I mean and that was later I don't like
at first I was just really interested in
those peak states yes and then what
would happen you know thinking hey
standing up on top of the mountaintop
being able to look at the world below
that perspective should yeah super
helpful yeah and then you go back and
shoulder your pack down in the forest
but you know your destination you've got
a lock on it you have faith you're not
just like why are we doing this and when
when we got there is you've had a
glimpse of the promised land so you can
go back to fetching water and chopping
wood with equanimity 100% and and I
think we were talking about this earlier
but you also end up with a somatic
marker like a felt sense in your body
you know and that's important
all right which is the opposite of our
trauma so which so we we have a sense of
wholeness even if it's fleeting even if
it's brief and it becomes a lodestone
mmm right it becomes a reason to keep
going lodestone for the Restless mind
and and then ideally you know and so
this gets back to the passing versus
abiding you know like how do we go from
flashes in the pan to actually living a
life of purpose that integrates these
things because there's a reason why
there's been a lot of social opprobrium
against them and about them it tends to
lead to bohemian excesses slackness of
will we don't want confused thinking so
there's always been a don't go to your
there be dragons mmm come back inside
yeah the walls sure so my sense is is
that yeah well once you get up the
message hang up the phone and the idea
of like ideally we can stitch together
our peak experiences with our waking
life and we can raise we can literally
you know kind of rate you know basically
you're taking your peaks and you're
plowing them into your valleys mm-hmm
and then you end up with a higher
plateau AHA because there is a
sense of you know that makes sense in
mountaineering there's a Death Zone
right above 26,000 feet we ain't
supposed to be there right right and you
can go there yeah you can't live there
for long right and so that sense is it
is down in the valleys yeah there are
homes that are children that our
families that are farms oh that's where
life is yeah first and so the and yet
there is nothing like sunrise on the top
of the mountain looking over an entire
snowpack mountain range and of being the
only humans for miles
yeah and it puts you right with the
world is so much grazing so much poetry
in it and let me ask you about this this
phrase you talk about the somatic
knowing is um that that sounds to me a
little bit like felt experience yeah it
was a felt experience you know cuz I
read a marvelous article called some a
on magazine by a guy called
Chris let abhi he's a philosopher of
science or philosopher of mind out of
Australia and he talks about how
psychedelics you know a psychedelic
therapy or psychedelics work by
violating our expectations of reality so
by giving us an experience that violates
our default understanding of the way
things are we are mortal beings life is
inherently meaningless we die but that
psychedelics or any experience of an
altered state you know standing of the
some of the mountain at the summit of
the mountain at the top of the mountain
at sunrise these kinds of experiences
seem to provide us with an encounter
that seems to violate that previous
literal grid interpretation of what we
are it gives us another place to plant
our feet another way of seeing things
his language is that these kinds of
ecstatic experiences provide knowledge
by acquaintance versus knowledge by
description so you can take you know a
person with treatment-resistant
depression
or just an existentialist who has
depressed over the fact that we are
mortal beings and you could tell him
with words hey dude you know there's
another perspective here there's another
way of seeing who and what we are you
know another interpretive framework that
actually won't cause you such disquiet
you know and you can tell him that
but he's still depressed right because
he's still seeing the world through
those lenses of perception that prism of
expectation that is coloring his world
that's knowledge by description it
doesn't get through but knowledge by
acquaintance is the equivalent of
picking them up and putting them
physically on the Sun on the top of that
mountain at sunrise and that knowledge
by acquaintance is essentially that
somatic experience it's felt in the body
right it's an experience of what Verner
Hertzog might call ecstatic truth
essentially we're talking about the
domain of religious inspiration or
divination but it matters not whether
the the content of that experience meets
empirical reality standards what matters
is according to this article the
epistemic value of those experiences in
that when you come down from the
mountain you are now more willing to
serve your community your more inspired
your trait openness can shift a whole
level you're no longer depressed you
know that's why these psychedelic
psychotherapy are so breathtakingly
effective seemingly in curing people of
the pathologies of mind although I want
to actually challenged on some of that
no no some of that late research of
course but what do you think of this
idea that this notion of the knowledge
by acquaintance versus the knowledge by
description for sure I mean you know
Soren Neale Hurston okay famously back
in the 20s said you got to go there and
know that that's it I love how you just
took like four and a half minutes of me
trying to explain this essay to you yeah
you got to go there to know there it's
exactly right that's it exactly right
and then you know cuz life is a grind
later there's good chunks of it that is
in that chop wood carry water bust ass
and it wears us down you know as Rocky
Balboa the great philosopher said it'll
beat you to your knees right so we do
have to have places where
we can stand tall where we can stretch
our bones where we can set down our
loads if only for a moment and go oh
[ __ ] yeah this is me at full height full
strength hmm with vision and we're
resilient creatures we are hardwired to
do the right thing the good thing we're
hardwired to grow and connect and so
it's just that the grind can beat us
down and so the ability from time to
time all right
to set our burdened like glory glory
hallelujah right when I lay my burden
down and like that's a beautiful thing
and so like I don't think we need much
we don't need to overindulge and and to
go back to the you know early research
on the psychedelic therapies and the
breakthroughs and I'm you know 100% in
favor and support of that work and
having that provide access and hope to
people who have been suffering treatment
resistant trauma depression anxiety all
of that and we are quite likely on the
tippity top of a hype cycle and the
early most breathless reporting mm-hmm
right because for any you know if
psychedelics were that much of a magic
bullet then the baby boomers would all
be like Jedi High Council and instead of
crispy librarians right and and so we
have to like measure this that clearly
the first few experiences asymmetrically
impactful because they literally just go
from default 21st century normal trapped
in my monkey suit to hate
topic about that there's more there's
more and so just that move from I
thought this was all there was to having
a somatic experience a felt experience
of there's actually a whole lot more
that is profound and life-changing but
it does not absolve us of navigating the
human condition right in that expanded
landscape it doesn't provide a
helicopter ride back to the summit
mm-hmm we just know it's there we just
know it's there and when and somatic
means in the body yeah right so having a
somatic experience which in the words of
Chris leatherby an experience of
knowledge by acquaintance
directly acquainted being placed on the
top of the mountain at sunrise versus
being told that there's a beautiful
mountain chair Mountaineers while
reading their National Geographic yeah
yeah exactly
that a somatic experience functions
essentially in the same way as trauma
does you know one of the most
interesting takes on how trauma can
inform our lives is was written by David
lensing in his book on the phenomenology
of altered states on drugs where he says
that an experience of like Perpetual
anxiety or acute anxiety with people who
suffer from panic disorder for example
are experiencing a kind of temporal
dislocation temporal dislocation so
they're not they're not being here now
yeah in fact what what happened is
according to him that an early trauma so
it's a negatively impacting somatic
experience in the body right an early
trauma is now over over judging or over
perceiving the present the past
experience right it's brought to the
doorstep of every moment and informing
your perception of every moment it's
like PTSD right every moment feels
dangerous even when clearly it's not but
you bring that sense of danger that
hyper vigilance because of that somatic
past trauma to the doorstep of every
moment and in turn conjure up a future
that becomes identified with doom and
both I think depression and anxiety are
both experiences where the person is not
able to meet the present directly but is
negatively pre configuring everything
that's happening because of that
negative somatic experience so here's
where it gets interesting
so that's trauma and you could argue
that just being born and becoming aware
of mortality is an early somatic Trump
but roland griffiths out of johns
hopkins university he's doing the
psilocybin trials to treat people with
death anxiety related to cancer he
likens a positively impactful mystical
experience mediated by mushrooms in this
case that meets all the criteria of
Williams
and the mystical experience question are
like the the deeper the mystical
experience it ends up functioning as an
inverse PTSD so also somatic but
positively so and just like trauma on a
somatic level ends up having all these
negative consequences in your life when
you go back to the day-to-day the
positive inverse PT XPS seeing the light
having the encounter the knowledge by
acquaintance on the top of the mountain
ends up being a somatic experience
that's positive so that when you come
back into the valley of the everyday as
you say you meet every day with a little
more grace a little more kindness a
little more patience a little more
empathy and that seems to be enough to
get by yeah yeah well yeah and I mean my
sense is like you know basically any of
these ineffable states mm-hmm you know
from flow States to mystical States and
cetera
tend to occur temporally in you know
what researchers would call like the
deep now so it's kind of a quintessence
of being where you're just a hundred
percent absorbed and it feels not just
that it's the present moment but it's
almost sort of everywhere everyone yes
all at once yes right yes and in the
sort of like Gnostic Christian tradition
that's like the intersection like the
the mystic interpretation of the Cross
is is Kairos Chronos right and the idea
sacred time is the vertical axis axis
mundi forever and always and the Chi and
Chronos is clock time our little
piddling lives who night and we're
normally on that horizontal axis but if
we get really if we do our homework and
we're lucky one day we end up at that
intersection and there is like for the
Rosicrucians right is the rosy cross of
Christ consciousness which is I am I am
aware of my eternal nature and being at
the same time that I am yoked to the
mortal coil and it is it is that is that
blissful crucifixion right it is both
exquisite and agonizing and and I think
a lot of the overly optimistic you know
kind of you know transformational
culture you know psychedelic Renaissance
bubble
is is buying into the idea that we can
kind of get off the mortal coil there we
can somehow dodge or solved them the
human condition and best as I can tell
that's a fool's errand you know the
harder we struggle against it the
stronger the snapback interesting so you
sit down is okay so it's sewed for me it
would be then you know and I think I
remember I remember action we do both
wit bit which well can we can we can we
find the Grace and the equanimity of
Chronos and Kairos while still actively
working to develop new therapies new
technologies new medicine to extend life
and extend our health span and so on and
so forth yeah yeah I mean I think we're
off the hook
yeah off the hook for our neurotic Woody
Allen's and a life of meaningless but
you know surfaces we're off that hook
like that's solvable okay but the cost
is we're on the cross all right can we
actually be awake and aware of the
totality of the human experience without
flinching and without contracting our
aperture and that is that's that
blissful crucifixion please like it is
exquisite and it is obliterating and and
and most folks I don't want to sign up
for that actually well it's a lot to ask
I want to skim the cream I don't want to
churn the butter well yeah I mean I do
understand what you're saying and so
much poetry of course in what you're
saying but but it's also super practical
like like love someone like every single
marriage ends in at least one person
broken and grieving at least a hundred
percent of marriages
it's either divorce or if the bearing or
you're burying your partner and yet we
all get back up to that altar and say
till death do we part I promise right
that that is hope eternal like raise
children and if you do a great job they
leave the door you give them a two
decades of your life and they leave if
you've done it right and don't look back
bury your parents and find that giant
wheel of the mortal coil ratcheting one
step forward and you're now on the
shotgun see it all right I mean like
like the human experience is irreducibly
filled
with grief but it can be something that
we've we experience as beautiful and
profound and our a privilege to be
present for or it can be that rage rage
against the dying the light well which
is I think is equally romantic by the
way I think we [ __ ] do it all like and
yeah well exactly I mean look everything
you're saying resonates with me and and
and sounds like you know the closing
lines are the most magnificent play I
mean it's it's beautiful but like what I
think is equally beautiful is our our
capacity to say right to exercise our
will and saying I didn't sign up for
these terms and for sure
and our you know we've doubled the human
lifespan we're about to turn biology
into a programmable medium you know
health and medicine are gonna be like
upended and transformed already the
things that we engender in the world are
of a level of complexity that you know
seems inconceivable to me in some ways
you know and you have some philosophers
like Kevin Kelly you know from from
Wired magazine who says that the things
that we engender in the world are tools
and technologies are actually extensions
of our biology and he describes this
almost extra core anti-entropic move
towards greater complexity and
organization in the form of our tools
and technologies he says we're smack in
the middle between the born and the made
and we're gonna create artificial minds
and yeah
why shouldn't mortality just be
something else to be overcome just like
we overcame gravity with our aircrafts
or we overcame distance and geography
with our smartphones you know when I
hear amber case describe a telephone
call as the techno social wormhole where
consciousness is can meet each other and
fold space and time essentially I think
to myself well I mean if we can do that
then we can do anything I mean this you
know what it turns McKenna say we we're
the coral reef like animal or the
extruder
technological material we've taken
matter of low organization we put it
through the filters of the mind and we
extrude something like this why can't we
extrude ever longer lifespans why can't
we extrude non-biological minds I mean
as magnificent as the Bliss of a
crucifixion is there is a part of me
that wants to or needs to believe that
there is more to us than that and rose
to go down on that yeah right okay right
so to your point on and I could just be
a little kid who's a skater scared of
death but I just I still think there's
something beautiful about us saying like
we will never [ __ ] give in you know
like here we are and what the [ __ ] you
know like yeah so now there's there's
several forces yeah yeah wonderful
conversation so so one is to go with
Kevin yeah and his point yeah right that
all of our tools are really just
extensions of us yeah as well as our
ability to transcend the limit the
apparent limitations of hidebound
mortality yeah okay and I would agree in
the sense that I think we are wildly I
mean some I forget her this was what it
was in the conversation around Ian
Moscone yeah yeah
living in a simulation yeah and it was
someone just basically saying why are we
carbon-based chauvinists like wide
what's wrong with silicon intelligence
like why do we think that carbon-based
life forms suddenly somehow have
privilege there you go right so that's
question one and the other is
anthropocentric consciousness like why
do we locate ourselves in carbon-based
primates as the center of the universe I
mean no surprise why we have right but
now we're smart enough to know better
yeah like dolphins - AI - you know Aspen
forests - fungal networks you're like
huh there's a lot of ways information is
exchanged processed and acted on full by
a whole bunch of different ones yes so
just off our anthropocentrism for a
second you're like yeah probably there's
all kinds of different ways even the
nominal extinction of the human race if
it were an adaptation of style
consciousness yes upload it to computers
that self propagate and do whatever meet
there would be some morning right in the
transitions and good old
Batarian creative destructions a [ __ ]
to be on the shop end of right but but
maybe so right and there could be a a
yielding or relaxing right so let's say
that's us that's still us in some form
of agency over yeah our own
transitioning yeah into what's next yeah
right and then back to this the whole
you know the theme we've laid out so far
yeah of why bother with peak states
what's their valley yeah the positing
eliminations two abiding like yeah and
then Kairos cross yeah right so it
appears and I don't all I can say is
what was your description it was the
term it was effective what was the way
of somatic oh oh na llege by
acquaintances acquaintances yeah yeah
yeah okay so if it has you lucky enough
fortunate enough to stumble into that
intersection of cars and cross mm-hmm
often more than once and you could let's
call it the garden let's to say it's
daddy Garden of Eden yeah I that he done
in Paradise the whole is outside of time
yeah the Grail Castle the Loving Cup
yeah for me it's the climactic moment in
my favorite music it's the cathartic
peak of the song yeah and what and what
is the cost of admission right the cost
of admission is everything you thought
you were and all your pain and all your
stories so it's ego death that's very
true you do not pass the veil
unless you have you unless you are
stripped to your essential being mmm
okay so you have experienced that dying
mmm unto all my preferences my pleasure
my pain my stories my yearnings my
longings my pride my fears right and
then you went to the UN to the garden
you know [ __ ] past present future it's a
whole the rising is a little perfect
yeah and you can maybe even apprehend
this all works out this all this all
[ __ ] works out amazing so now what do
we do right we come back to waking state
3d right the fever dream fades yeah we
are just you know Dorothy waking up back
on the phone yeah but we know we're like
oh I've seen yeah I read the last page
of the book
yeah so now I know and this is the you
loosening and mystery that right there
was a death cult
there was an ecstatic death cult it
taught you how to
hmm and once you've already died right
then you come back in mortal so now I
know how the movie ends I'm back in my
meat suit but I've shouldered that that
suit willingly this dressing and now I
know in my bones that I am simply living
out the middle chapters of the greatest
story ever told
so these kinds of experiences of of ego
death this knowledge by acquaintance
this glimpse glimpse of the promised
land this is this access to Eden he's an
F scott Fitzgerald F got F scott
Fitzgerald's line he says he's
transitory enchanted moments in which
man must have held his breath compelled
into aesthetic contemplations he barely
understood nor desired face to face for
the last time in history with something
can measure it his capacity for wonder
which what you're saying then is that at
the end of the movie experientially and
perceptually time falls away space-time
and mind collapse into one wonderful
ecstatic cathartic merger Union Omega
point and then all these questions they
all become just badly posed questions in
the end like cuz cuz because we in this
absolution it's almost like a divination
but like something happens that makes
everything else fall away and none of it
ultimately matters yeah it's like that
old joke about you don't ever find the
answer to the meaning of the universe
you just stop asking the [ __ ]
question right and so like that like
that death rebirth is the what in the
esoteric traditions was like gnosis
mmm-hmm right the sense of like oh I was
walking along thinking I was meeting
right I was whole yeah I realized I
wasn't that was a cardboard cutout now
I've actually been initiated into a
profound embody knowing and are
remembering because I mean there's
always there's moments in peak states of
a bananas's of that forgetting of the
forgetting and remembering what I had
forgotten yeah
and I always thinking like that Disney
movie was like Sleeping Beauty where
like the entire kingdom is asleep and
there's thickets and brambles and then
the prince comes and loves true kiss and
everyone wakes up midstream back in the
enchanted world really and I mean that
is a persistent phenomena that people
experience if like oh yeah yeah I
remember in fact not I do I remember the
thing I swore that is so central and so
true
but I also remember the last time I was
here and had access to it do you think
that what what is felt in those moments
also you know you lose your
individuality so you you have a you are
all and all is you you are everyone and
everyone is you is that is that a
qualitative feature of the experience
because it just occurred to me when you
were describing this is one of the
things I've always wondered about is the
phenomenon the the subjective phenomena
of becoming engrossed in the film so
when you're watching a movie there's
this wonderful article by Diana Slattery
what she was talking about immersion and
she was talking about like absolutely
mixed attention immersion for being
fully immersed essentially disappearing
into that which you are beholding as
Terence Mckenna says becoming what you
behold immersion is a prerequisite for
any interpersonal experience a
transformation education or persuasion
to take place and she was talking about
what happens let's say when you when you
lose yourself you lose your sense of
self in a story there's something called
the Dietetic shift the directing shift
is the moment in watching a movie where
you now assume the viewpoint of the
character so you're no longer a person
in the theatre looking at the screen now
you're actually inside the character
looking out through his eyes like
phenomenologically you know subjectively
you have this felt experience you assume
the viewpoint of the character and you
know it's hard to keep that dream stable
you can easily be distracted and pop
back into yourself if somebody turns on
a cell phone in the movie theater but
there is a period of time in which you
assume the viewpoint of that character
and you undergo in this Kairos like
space inside the movie theater you
undergo the hero's journey you undergo
his journey you have the Bliss [ __ ]
crucifixion you submit you know and then
you die and then you are reborn I mean a
religious experience can happen just
inside of watching the movie
but I guess my question has always been
like I take great comfort in these
moments because I have an experience
that's real but that didn't happen to me
but that's real yeah and so you get in
the Learning Labs without having to
without having the the wear and tear
sure yeah but I wouldn't even call it
cheating but I was saying do you think
that that's I can an intimation or I
mean it's an experience that that in
itself shows you that things can happen
to you without you being there does that
does that make sense so like the anxiety
about one's body and one's aging and
one's death like that doesn't matter
when you're watching moving you've
become that character because that
character you're in an archetypal realm
and that character is you and you are
that character and that character is
everyone and you know you you are now in
a mythopoetic archetypal space there's
very interesting research on that and
like even just readers adult readers of
fiction versus nonfiction and the folks
that read fiction with complex character
development crisis excited everything
you're talking about yeah actually
develop greater emotional intelligence
and resiliency and express less anxiety
and depression so you really we get to
work ourselves out right via imaginal
you know shadowing mm-hmm right of
effective characters which is magic
yeah and you know imaginal shadowing
effective characters I mean that's yeah
I remember reading rich Doyle's book
when he was talking about dreams or in
this case waking dreams like when you
watch films you know it's a waking dream
he says dreams do not lack reality they
are real patterns of information yeah so
I mean it's still a real event I guess I
guess I guess what I'm speculating about
here is merging with the character on
screen is just one example or one
intimation one invitation to consider
the ways in which there is more to us
than just the meatsuit and the monkey
mind exactly ourselves we can become
liminal beings that experiences can
happen in consciousness where time
dilates spacetime gets inverted
that there are these domains it doesn't
have to be psychedelics it can just be
like watching a freaking film that
really sucked you in you know or showing
what is through the looking-glass yeah
take you the pierced through the
looking-glass in some ways you know yeah
I mean Stan Grof you know you talk you
know coined the term holotropic and most
people associate that just with breathe
3 specifically hyperventilate or
anything okay but really it just means
moving towards wholeness
so he actually and so he distinguishes
it's actually a qualifier so you can
have a psychedelic experience that is
holotropic you can also have one that's
psychotic or neurotic right so that is a
healing movement you can do a breath
work session you could do travel you
could do prayer or a song or odd and
that can be holotropic or not so I think
decoupling it from lying on the floor
breathing fast is really neat because
you're like oh what ecstatic experiences
those that take us outside our so our
holotropic that move us towards home
yeah right and so my inquiry that I mean
a there is that notion when you dream
about dreams being legitimate their own
organizing information and that's do
fictive film that's right right so yeah
that you know that gets to the role of
the value of peak States in the sense
that you know we are in monophasic
culture that has one channel of
acknowledged reality that's right five
senses empirical rationalist it's right
post French enlightenment right in a
scientific method and everything else is
suspect it's also why actually why the
second death - anse has made headway as
medical interventions and ketamine works
because of the gaba receptors and it has
this uptick and depression never mind
the K whole let's not talk about that
and where people go right we're gonna
talk about gaba receptors and we're not
going to talk about psilocybin in the
sense of its connecting you with
whatever branches of non ordinary
reality it might write we're saying hey
Sarah T full mode Network it's a great
[ __ ] card game we need that literal
grid for now because it is the the
operating principle on which most of us
are moving I think it would be sure
disruptive if we didn't if he told him
about the bats
tell them about the bats and so like
there is there's a legit question which
is that's something we this is like you
know it's like stranger things that's
like any of our stories yeah what
happens when the cat gets out of the bag
what Schrodinger's cat gets out of the
bag yeah and then we start actually
living into a world that does not behave
the way the old one was supposed to Wow
you think we'll ever be able to surf
those domains to become like ninjutsu
could you Jitsu masters of those domains
without getting locked up in a padded
room or losing our way you know like
it's just because yeah I take great
comfort from ecstasy's from going beyond
myself with with you know I I'm very
susceptible to trance when I watch
movies I disappear and that's why I
cling to them the way people cling to
the cross though cuz I'm like that
movies like you know I hold it close to
my heart because I it's taking me to
different domains it's it's exposed me
to aesthetic orgasms you know I've I
lost myself and found myself surfing
that cinematic wave right Jean
Youngblood and expanded cinema says
cinema reflects mankind's historical
capacity or desire to manifest his
consciousness outside of his mind in
front of his eyes you know consciousness
meets its own process when we lose
ourselves in a film
Hugo Merton burg in 1912 when writing
about the photoplay said cinema right
actually mimics consciousness more than
mimics empirical reality that's why we
didn't have to be taught to watch films
the close-up represents attention the
flashback represents memory the
foreshadowing represents future modeling
so consciousness works more like a movie
than like empirical reality so we meet
ourselves there we know that space
because that's a kind of ecstatic space
at least it has been for me but I I
don't doubt that psychedelic experiences
or for you you know mountains mushrooms
and the Grateful Dead
we're also encounters with domains where
you weren't there or you were more than
you and then all the anxieties of the
human condition fall away essentially
right yeah but there was actually
something about the interrelationship of
those things that is that I think is
important and gets to the question of
integration right and the passing
elimination is becoming abiding yeah so
what do you do when you leave the movie
theater
what are you doing the concerts over
what do you do when the lights come back
up for sure and and so integration
application is ultimately scoreboard you
know the sort of the difference between
an alchemist and an addict right is the
score mm-hmm and either you were
engaging in that process and that and
that is why I like I mean we
accidentally you know ended up in grad
school in Boulder plugged into the very
vibrant you know extreme sports
Mountaineer and guiding backcountry
skiing etc plus the tag into the Alpha
hippies a lot of the McKenna brothers
crew and that world and it had been a
high-water mark as the reagan-thatcher
years and everything else had kind of
come and swept away the the earlier
Renaissance that was where it lived
mm-hmm it lived in Telluride and Crested
Butte and Boulder right and there were
mountain throw downs and hoedowns and
everybody was turned on
but during the daytime people calibrated
and tested their mettle so compared to
like hippies on the west coast they
could just lounge around and play
hobbits in the woods and nothing would
ever gut-check right it was hey there
you're in an avalanche zone you might
die today hey you need your wilderness
medical training like get your [ __ ]
together like hey if you're hypothermic
if you go wandering around in your back
and stocks you're gonna get a lost thing
get cold and die so there was a shop and
an defacing basically was the element of
Kali right it was actually facing
mortality and people in those
communities died every single season
right I mean we lost you know we were
ten funerals and had you lost dozens and
friends and colleagues to rockfall
avalanches whitewater drownings like
this is the real [ __ ] and so to combine
those experiences with communitas with
celebration on live music with beautiful
natural places and with gravity and its
consequences alright and and therefore
having to level up into a wake aware
capable responsible humans right that
piece is missing I didn't realize how
lucky we were as the bottom line because
we were lucky lucky or you
there were there was a number of close
calls but but but lucky I mean and
people have so many preconceptions about
the Grateful Dead interesting lucky to
be initiated into the Arcana Americana
alright this is the living scriptures of
the gospel folk blues and then
psychedelic music traditions because
interesting it was a profoundly living
scripture and and that and I think
cinema is that for me but what it did is
is no one in the mountains no one is
part of that community ever ran off and
join a guru cult
none of them ever succumb to soft and
fuzzy thinking this is pretty Instagram
pre you know internet marketing a bunch
of things but people were humble yeah
and the more the more badass you were
the less you talked or promoted it
everybody tested their mettle against
true life and death yeah everyone then
had their peak ecstatic experiences in
God's Cathedral with their brothers and
sisters and it became an amazingly
focused crucible for raising
high-performing homegrown humans and and
so it's only lately as I've been trying
to assess like transformational culture
Burning Man culture psychedelic
Renaissance and being like what's
missing why are we doing these dumb ass
things right now that I've
retrospectively come to profoundly
appreciate your though the way you
culture we got initiated into just by
the by so yeah mmm-hmm so in bringing
that back then you know beautiful I
turning our passing illuminations into
abiding light integrating this this
glimpse of wholeness so that we can in
your words turn our leaky buckets into
chalices and render ourselves whole can
you just spend the last couple of
minutes real quick on you know practical
applications that we thankfully have
like what's happening in psychology
technology neurobiology pharmacology the
four forces of ecstasy that is giving us
this
unique capacity now to steward our
access to these ecstatic and
information-rich states and and then
bringing contending with those states
bringing that back integrating it into
our wholeness
so that way me so that we may you know
do a better job at being humans and and
scale access to these domains that can
heal us of our fractures because we so
badly need to in this [ __ ] mental
health crisis epidemic
yeah for sure all right ready yeah okay
so in a nutshell yeah the ecstasy is the
peak state tends to remind us of what we
figure out and gives us a sense of
completion wholeness beauty yes and it
also gives us our laundry list of [ __ ]
we haven't figured out yet it's
basically like an electrician running a
voltmeter through our nervous systems
and you're like oh you're banged up here
you're contracted here might be a
physical injury from the past it might
be an emotional wound it might be
whatever it is right but we could tend
to get staggeringly clear readouts of
all the places that energy does not move
cleanly through our system okay right so
back to the abiding light where the
holes in our colander we get a punch
list here's all your holes buddy mm-hmm
so now I can either come back down and
be like okay that's my homework now I
can engage and dedicate it practice to
stop patching my holes and I actually
have you know good material because I
still have the light and the inspiration
right that I afterglow the off to glow
and so I'm a little bit more courageous
I'm a little less contract that's right
and I can use that light to kind of fill
in some of my shares and do your
homework
yeah and in connection in communitas
means am I am I doing this in service
for you for us does this deepen our
connection does this further our goals
and that's a wheel like that experience
of ecstasy is catharsis communitas is
forever rolling us forward through our
lives right and some of those practices
are dead simple like how do we how do we
turn our colander into a chalice so the
simplest is it's like upgrade our
nervous system I'll separate our nervous
bottom line because then the next time
you have a jolt of light you don't blow
all your fuses and you don't do
manic-depressive like either I'm a
golden God or [ __ ] nothing nothing
matters right because that's what's too
much too much of that in like some of
the Burning Man bliss junkie culture
where it's like you know pay the price
of admission have three days of Hayek's
tasses and then like three weeks of
depression and then start planning for
next year instead exactly so you know
basically most folks out of the box like
you know 21st century zoo animals
we are only running things cognitively
so average so if you suddenly introduced
peak States into someone who's stuck
behind living behind their eyes yes it's
basically giving the hamster wheel of
your mind like giving that little [ __ ]
a shot at crystal meth and now he just
goes even faster yeah handle that energy
just right your brain that's right in
your mind in your stories you will short
all those sets so you have to bring it
down into your body and you do that with
breath you do that with movement you do
that with spinal articulation pelvic
mobility like functional movement and
monkey [ __ ] as well as awareness of
respiration and its integration with
Vega on the tone right and the ability
to move brain wave states skillfully so
I'm gonna be hyper focused in
high-functioning beta
I'm more relaxed and expansive in alpha
I can become deeply come template of and
theta right and and so I do that via
respiration movement including as I said
fashion and attention to vagal nerve
tone then sexuality just sexual fitness
as a baseline because it's it's the most
strongly encoded evolutionary driver we
have so if you and it's responsible for
most of our suffering and trauma by
accidentally including babies like hey
you rub your [ __ ] together it's [ __ ]
awesome Oh joke's on you guys nine
months later you have a kid right dad
that is a that is a bitch-slap of
evolution and we kinda talked about the
stone date being the arching of how we
got to being PSA pians the eating
mushrooms act in line right it's more
like the horned ape it's actually our
ability to mate outside of estrus
alright and to perpetuate prolonged
sexuality that is the unlocking move
it's unlike any other primates and
there's only like two or three other
animal species in the entire world that
even remotely approximate what we do so
include that and then include music
because it even predates language and is
one of the most potent state shifters
and then finally substances as
sacraments how do I shift state
skillfully like that sweet is what we
can use to take the information from our
peak states and integrand yeah and
integrate our trauma and then connect
test apply and refine in relationship
with others beautiful and if we do that
then then we have a shot right we have a
shot at living into the better angels of
our nature
yeah range which I which I love that
that idea what it sounds like these
tools and techniques these technologies
this applied knowledge it gives us a way
of metabolizing the passing
illuminations and in metabolizing them
we become them this is a great essay I
once read about epigenetics right and
one of the scientists said something
like ourselves can be or are a
technology that turns experience into
biology so when I hear you metaphor but
sort of not really right Leppa genetic
we become our experiences or we are
there some of our experiences when I
hear you talk about all of this there's
these body exercises and the nervous
system simulation the vagal nerve stuff
I'm paraphrasing whatever saying it so
eloquently but that that's a way of kind
of doing the thing that helps us to
metabolize into the body those passing
illumination so that those passing
illuminations become part of the they
become instantiated downloaded into our
bodies and so they they they end up they
end up living that metaphor our cells
act then become this technology that
turns this these experiences into
biology we become the light and then
it's that needs that guard not the line
you told me the other world is this
world rightly seen right because once we
once we metabolize that fully well then
[ __ ] man then that default world is no
longer because now we we see the North
Star right it is life and practice as
the yoga of becoming amen
Jamie wheel thanks for your time brother
appreciate you